Transcriber: Rama Balawi
المدقّق: sultana idris
♪ طلعت يا ما أحلى ♪
♪ نورها شمس الشموسة ♪
السلام عليكم، كيف حالكم؟
أنا الحسن البخاري، أنا هنا اليوم
لأطلعكم على ثلاثة أشياء:
أولاً: أنا لم أفهم ما قاله هذا الرجل،
إن كان يشتم فأخبروني.
ثانياً، أثناء تجهيزنا لهذا الحديث،
واجهتنا مشكلة كبيرة
وهي أني لا أبتسم أثناء التحدث،
لدرجة أن أحداً أخبرني أن حاجبي معقودين
هل وصل الأمر لدرجة معقودين!
بالتأكيد هذه مشكلة يجب حلها
وبدأت أفكر كيف أحلها
فكان أبسط حل هو أن أبتسم
اِبتسامة كبيرة فى بداية الحديث،
وأنتم خذوها ووزعوها
كما تشاؤون على باقي الحديث.
ثالث شيء هو لُب الموضوع،
عن ماذا سأتحدث؟
جئت اليوم لأتحدث عن كيف
بدأ الطحلب.
كيف اِنتقل برنامج طحالب
من برنامج تحت الإنشاء،
مشاهدته صفر،
إلى أن وصلنا
في حلقة من حلقاتنا
لأربعة عشر مليون مشاهدة.
كيف بدأ هذا؟
ما هي الخطوات التى اِتخذتها؟
بدايتي كانت كالآتي،
كنت أعمل في مجال الإنتاج الإعلامي،
وصدقني إنه مجال ممل جداً.
يوم تقوم بإعلان صابون
ويوم آخر معجون، ويوم إعلان شامبو.
تحدثتُ أنا و زملائي وقلنا: لماذا لا نصنع
برنامج يناقش قضايا اِجتماعية!
نسمع الناس ويسمعونا، نتكلم معهم
ويتكلموا معنا، نضجرهم ويضجروننا.
ماذا سنسمي البرنامج؟
فكرنا في أسماء عشوائية كثيرة
وفي النهاية، اِستقرينا على اِسمين
إما أن نُسميه طحالب أو صقور الكيوي
على حسابي الخاص
أنشأت تصويت بين الناس
ولسبب ما أجهله،
أعجبت الناس جداً باِسم طحالب.
إذاً، فليكن طحالب.
أول حلقة كانت عن التحرش.
أتذكر جيداً أننا نشرنا الحلقة مساء
يوم الخميس، يعني غداً الجمعة.
قلت لزملائي: أتمنى أن نوصل بعد
صلاة الجمعة لخمسة عشر ألف مشاهدة
اِستيقظنا اليوم التالي، صلينا الجمعة،
ثم وجدنا أن الحلقة وصلت 500,000 مشاهدة.
كانت مفاجأة سعيدة جداً بالنسبة لنا،
ردود فعل الناس تجاوزت التوقعات بكثير
كنا سعداء للغاية
هل أنا مبتسم الآن؟
ونشرنا الحلقة الثانية، ثم الثالثة
وفي كل مرة تتزايد المشاهدات
حتى وصلنا لأربعة عشر مليون مشاهدة.
حسناً، لماذا أُعجب الناس بطحالب؟
لماذا اِنتشر طحالب بين الناس؟
لماذا الناس مقتنعين بطحالب ويرددون
جُمله الكوميديا وينتظرون مواعيد عرضه.
صانعي المحتوي على مواقع
التواصل الاِجتماعي كثيرون، لست بمفردك
وأخف ظلٍ منك.
بالطبع لا، أنا أخفُ ظلاً منهم
لكنني أتواضع من أجل هذا الحديث.
الكثيرون يقدمون محتوى مثلك،
لماذا تعلقت الناس بك ويعرفون اسم طحالب
وينتظرون مواعيد حلقاتك؟
أستطيع أن أُلخص السبب
من وجهة نظري في كلمة واحدة.
القيمة.
القيمة هي التي جعلتنا ننتقل
من أول حلقة إلى أن وصلنا بعد ذلك
لأربعة عشر مليون مشاهدة
أن يشاهد الشخص محتواك
ويعلم أنه سيضحك و يستمتع وسيرى
كوميديا وسخرية وهكذا،
لكن في النهاية .ستستفيد
حسناً، كيف تضيف قيمة لمحتواك؟
ماذا سيساعدك
على إضافة شيء مفيد تعرضه للناس؟
ستعرف إجابة هذا السؤال
بعد الإجابة على السؤال التالي.
أنا -الذي يريد تقديم قيمة إلى الناس-
مَن؟
من أنا؟
إن لم تكن تعرف نفسك
فلن تستطيع تقديم قيمة للناس
تخيل أنك دخلت على أسرة
ووجدت بينهم كائن ما
شيء ما، لا تعرف ما هو
يرتدي حذاء رياضي للبنات
و بنطال قصير للأولاد الصغار و قميص
للفتيات الصغار و لديه شارب.
من أنت إذاً؟ ما الفائدة منك؟
هل أتي إليك عندما أريد إغاظة والدتي
أم عندما أريد مصروفاً من والدي
هل ألعب مع أخي الصغير أم معك؟
من أنت؟
طالما هذا المخلوق لم يعرف نفسه
وأنت لم تكتشف ماهيته
لن يستطيع أن يقدم فائدة أبدااً
ولا يمكنك الإستفادة منه بشيء.
يجب عليك معرفة من أنت
حتى تستطيع معرفة ما الذي يمكنك تقديمه.
تتعجب من محتوى التيك توك
كله عبارة عن رقص ولعب بلا قيمة
لماذا؟ لأن صاحب المحتوى لم يكتشف نفسه.
كل الذي يعرفه هو أنه حين
نظر الى نفسه وجد مفاصل
فقرر تحريك المفاصل، فقط لا غير.
حسناً، أصبح واضحاً الآن أن تقديم القيمة
يعتمد على وضوح الهوية،
لأن القيمة مشتقة من الهوية.
حسناً، كيف أتعرف على هويتي؟
كيف أعرف من أنا؟
على ماذا ترتكز هويتي؟
من أنت وهويتك قائمة على ثلاثة أمور:
على لغتك،
على ثقافتك،
على دينك، هذا هو المثلث
الذي إذا اِتضح لك، ستعرف من أنت.
أول عنصر هو عنصر اللغة.
(خليط من الإنجليزية والعربية غير مفهوم)
يجب ان تكون فصيحاً مثل صديقنا هذا.
يعتقد الكثيرون أن اللغة مجرد حمام زاجل
تضع الفكرة
ثم توصلها للناس فقط لا غير،
هذا تصور قاصر عن اللغة.
اللغة هي طريقة للتفكير، لغتك الأم
هي الطريقة التي تصيغ بها
الفكرة في ذهنك قبل أن توصلها للناس.
أنت الآن تريد أن توصل فكرة أنا لا أسمعها
لكن هناك فكرة في ذهنك، وهذه الفكرة بلغة،
إذا كانت اللغة مشوشة وغير واضحة
الفكرة ستكون غير واضحة ومشوشة.
على قدر وضوح اللغة في ذهنك
على قدر وضوح الفكرة
على قدر تشوش اللغة، على قدر تشوش الفكرة.
إذا كنت لست منتمياً إلى لغتك الأم
لا تعرف صوتك الداخلي يتحدث بأي لغة
لن تتمكن من توصيل فكرتك للناس
بالطريقة التي تريدها
هذا لا يعني أن لا تتعلم لغات أخرى
تعلم لغة ولغتين، لكن يجب عليك
أن تعرف الهدف من تعلمك
يجب عليك معرفة أن لغتك الأم
هي لغة صوتك الداخلي.
ثاني عنصر من عناصر هويتك هو عنصر الثقافة.
أن تكون على معرفة بذاتك
أنك شخص عربي، أفريقي، ومصري الجنسية.
ثقافتنا هكذا
نحتفل بأسلوب معين ونحزن بأسلوب معين
مثل هذا الرجل،
اِسمعني يا سيد، اِخزي الشيطان
بالأدب والاِحترام
واِحضر لي مشروب بيبسي
لأن رأسي ناشف مثل المستشفى
وحين أغضب، ينمو لي شنب
وذيل وأذنان طويلتان
(صوت عوي ذئب)
طالما لديك فهم واضح لثقافتك
و عِلم بعادات وتقاليد الأفراح و الأحزان
وفهم لقيم مجتمعك
منتمي لها ومعتز بها
هكذا ستتعرف على نفسك
وعلى وكيفية تقديم الفائدة للناس
ستستطيع الحكم على الأشياء
اللائقة للمجتمع والغير لائقة للمجتمع
في حال كنت غير ملم بهذه المواضيع
ماهو لباسهم، أسلوب حديثهم..
ماهو تراثهم الشعبي، كيف يحزنون،
لن تعرف من أنت
ولن تقدر على أن تضيف شيء للناس.
هناك موقف قد أثر بي جداً،
كنت ذات مرة فى قرية ورأيت اِمرأة عجوز
تبلغ 70 عام تقريباً، كانت تمشي
ثم قابلت راجل أكبر منها عمرًا،
يبلغ تسعين عاماً، سلمت عليه وقبلت يده.
بغض النظر عن اِحتمالية صلة القرابة،
أو لماذا حدث هذا، لا أعرف التفاصيل
ولكن القيمة التي لفتت نظري،
هى قيمة اِحترام الكبير
المتجذرة فى مجتمعنا.
أن المرأة مهما كانت كبيرة سناً
لأنه أكبر منها سناً لذلك اِحترمته.
القيم الثقافية هذه إن كانت واضحة لديك
وأنت منتمي لها وتعتز بها،
إذاً يمكنك أن تقدم قيمة للناس.
الشئ الثالث هو الدين،
كل فرد منا ولد على دين
أعتنقه ويطبق شعائره
إذا كنت تعلم لماذا أنت منتمي لهذا الدين
مثلا، شخص ما يقول لك أنا متمسك بهذا الدين
لأنه يدعو إلى مكارم الأخلاق
يدعو إلى كذا..
وآخر يقول أن متمسك بهذا الدين
لأن فيه تسامح وعفو ومحبة.
طالما هذه المعالم واضحة فى نفسك،
هويتك ستكون واضحة لك.
وستقدر على أن تفيد الناس.
مثل هذا الرجل.
حسناً، أخيراً هناك شيء مهم جداً
أريد أن أخبرك به،
شيء مهما تقلبت الدنيا،
و مهما تغير الزمان،
مهما تعبت، لا تفعل ذلك.
♪ يا غزال يا غزال، العشق حلال ♪
♪ ذوبتني ذوب، خليتني خيال ♪
إياك أن تقوم بهذا فى محتواك.
أذان الناس ليست لعبة،
لا يجب أن تسمعهم صوت مثل هذا.
سيقول لي أحدهم،
حسناً، أنا شاب عمري ستة عشر،
أو ثمانية عشر، أشاهدك وأنتَ ظريف
وخفيف الظل، عرضت علينا فيديوهات ظريفة..
لكن ماذا تريد مني أنا أفعل؟
أود الإستفادة من هذا الحديث
كيف يمكنني أن أستفيد؟
أنشأ قناة واسميها
سبانخ مثل ما قمت أنت بطحالب،
وأستخدم أسلوب كوميدي مثلك؟
أو ماذا يجب أن أفعل؟
لا، في عصرنا هذا كل فرد منا
هو منصة تقديم محتوى.
حسابك على فيسبوك منصة تقديم محتوى،
سناب شات، تويتر، أنستغرام
تيك توك، كل مكان منهم
هو منصة تقديم محتوى.
حتى وأنت جالس مع أصدقائك في مقهى
الكلام الذى تقوله هو محتوى سمعي يسمع.
أنا هنا اليوم لأخبرك بأنه قبل أن تفكر
فى تقديم محتوى على أي منصة
مهما كان عدد المستمعين
كبير أو صغير،
يجب أن تقف وتسأل نفسك
سؤال واحد فقط،
ما هى القيمة التي سأقدمها للناس
فى المحتوى الذى سأقوم به.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)